on our show we want to put a spotlight
on people doing real good out in the
real world
and as the wildfires continue to affect
the west coast
there are countless stories of heroes
risking their lives
to help save their neighbors and our
next guest is one of those heroes
having saved countless lives and
countless other homes
while losing her own home joining us
from oregon please welcome the upper
mckenzie rural fire chief
chief christiana rainbow clues
thank you hello chief rainbow
oh i'm sorry thanks for having me i was
just gonna say thank you for coming here
take us through everything how has your
community been affected by the fires
um the community is
completely devastated um blue river is
gone
it's a small town in the cascade
foothills in oregon and it is completely
gone
um not only all the homes but all the
businesses including our fire station
um eight of my volunteer firefighters
have lost all of their belongings and
their homes
and you lost your home right chief
rainbow
i did i did i lost my home and my
neighboring home where my boys were
roommates is also gone
how have you dealt with this how have
you been able to
handle everything that's been you know
put on your plate that you've been
confronted with how are you coping
um it's really a roller coaster i'm
i'm up and down one minute i feel like
i'm strong enough to handle all of it
and the next minute i don't know
i'm completely lost i've been getting my
strength from my family
and i know that my firefighters are also
gaining
strength from their families and
our our strong partners all around us
in the fire community really supporting
us
can i ask you a question because
watching this story
i think of the you know person you know
in me that is here
watching a television in my kitchen how
do you tell yourself
i've lost my home my boys are struggling
i'm struggling what is the flip the
switch you flip to go back
out there and keep helping others while
you're dealing with that
somebody has to do it somebody has to
lead and somebody
has to help get the the healing and
the rebuilding process started
and i am the chief and
i am in the position to impact that
um so i just have to be strong and and i
have to
do it for everyone else hopefully we can
all find our way
we would like to do something for you
chief rainbow i was so invested in your
story and we spoke to our friends at
pastine
the oldest italian specialty foods in
north america
and they were just incredible and they
responded
and we wanted to give you this ten
thousand dollar check
on behalf of them and all of us at the
show
and i know it's not enough but
just a little start to say that you are
an inspiration to us all
and i'm going to be replaying that in my
mind over and over that
when you're in some of the hardest
situations
how you flip that switch and care for
others
i have learned a lot from you and i just
thank you for your dedication and
inspiration and talking with us today
so here's so much a little something not
enough but i thank our friends at
pastine
and thank you chief rainbow for being
the example to us
all we'll be right back thank you so
much thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
you